i also want to say uh how proud i am of
the comedy that we've done
uh on uh on the conan show uh so much
amazing writing uh here's just a
tiny tiny sample of some stuff that i
really like take a look
the national zoo has reopened i'm told
it's about to go online
right about now can we cut to the panda
can please
i think oprah's running out of ideas for
gifts open the box
[Music]
not joe
[Applause]
[Music]
where is minty conan please tell me
[Applause]
and one of the most striking images was
this shot of north korea's kim jong-un
arriving at the summit warner brothers
gave me my own
security detail okay that's me
coming back from the commissary
oh then i realized i forgot to get
ketchup
channing tatum and jenna dewan tatum
filed for divorce i'm sorry it's just
channing tatum is my celebrity free pass
you think he's gonna see this and reach
out why would he even go out with me
[Applause]
just get a hold of yourself dana what
channing really needs now is time with
his buddy
they say plants can even remember
something for several weeks
imagine if this whole time plants were
watching our behavior and remembering
everything
i can't take any die little chances
you gotta die die
sorry pal no
witnesses
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Applause]
so
introducing roblox oh you
can rub it on a chair you can rub it on
your hair you can rub it on a stair you
can rub it in the air you can rub it on
a pickle you can rub it on your nipples
you can rub it on a picture of the
reaper with a signal you can rub it on a
bagel you can
[Music]
i don't get what the rubbing has to do
with it well then you're an
idiot because with red light you
can rub another line you can rub a lot
of time you can rub it off people you
can rub it on time you can rub it on the
towel you're gonna rub it on an owl
you're gonna rub it on the lady who's
frozen in the sky oh why rubbing
can you please just tell me
no no no no no
no more tell
[Music]
[Applause]
baby is just wait a minute realizing now
that she's kim kardashian and kanye
west's child
the baby is making a breakthrough ladies
and gentlemen
the baby wants no part of this oh no
baby baby is getting away with the
placenta
baby will not be taken no baby getting
down the staircase
oh no benny using the placenta to get
into a police car he's hijacked a
motorcycle and he's headed this way
[Music]
is
i don't think you've got to say the
placentas and the side cards
we had to do that bit before someone
else would